uh one of the sort of fun things to
watch lately and it's fun in the sense
of
of it being uh disaster porn quite
frankly it's been to see not only the
radicalization of right-wing
media like newsmax and oan but also
seeing the low-rent characters that have
been introduced to us through these
networks so
we've come to know people like sydney
powell
and lynn wood uh mike lindell from
my pillow or as i like to call him mike
pillow
the various hosts and reporters on oan
and newsmax who
either couldn't get jobs at syria's news
outlets or used to work there and were
laid off or quit or
got fired or whatever the case may be i
have a new one for you today
all right newsmax interviewed a woman
named rachel hamm that's with two m's
h-a-m-m
rachel hamm is a barely known radical
right-wing
christian i have no idea why newsmax
even wanted to interview her
but they did and she went on air and she
said
donald trump has been the best thing for
christianity since jesus
yeah like jesus christ you know the guy
um
listen to this she is responding to
claims that some have made
that donald trump has not been a good
christian nor good for christianity
uh rachel hamm believes he has been
great
in fact a catastrophe for christianity
well i have to laugh president trump was
the best thing to happen to the
christian church
in america since maybe jesus so
yeah that's ridiculous i read the
article i thought
if it weren't i don't know i didn't know
if he actually believed the things he
was saying but he is not in touch with
what the evangelical church thinks at
all
so okay trump the best thing for
christianity since jesus
it sounds sort of weird but
this is a woman who's been invited to
speak so she must know what she's
talking about right
i don't know i have no idea why she's on
tv um
we researched rachel hamm she has a
youtube channel with
23 000 subscribers okay
she wrote a book called life beginning
which is about her connection to god and
she has a website where she sells
online courses and ebooks
and she will give you advice and this
type of thing so
i don't know what's more sad that
this is the person that newsmax was
able to get to talk about how great of a
christian
donald trump is or was or that newsmax
is even willing to have rachel ham on to
make these claims like i don't know
who's dragging down whom i it's not
completely clear to me and this by the
way is another example of the unhealthy
level of
idolizing politicians that i've been
warning about for years now i've warned
the left and right about this when i saw
cults of personality developing around
tulsi or andrew yang or bernie whoever
like agree disagree with people's
politics i think it's a bad idea to
deify any politicians that includes the
left and the right
this is taking it to the extreme the
best for christianity since jesus this
is very very
i mean again i you know these seem like
sick people to me to me this doesn't
seem like
uh it's someone who's emotionally well
placed within the within the world
but so much like we've been talking
about the republican party becoming
uh more about performative outrage this
is another
element of modern republicanism that is
either going to destroy the party
or they'll have to rule it root it out i
don't know that this is a party
that i mean you know a lot of us
obviously don't take people like rachel
ham
nor newsmax seriously as it is but to
the extent that newsmax will play a role
in the modern right-wing movement and
the republican party or the trump party
if trump is
decides to create a third party um this
is not going to be you know you and i
might say it's
it's obviously humiliating they won't
see it that way but i still don't think
it's useful
because there are republicans who find
this type of nonsense just
not good politics they think it's
unproductive for them and that's often
that's often the strongest word they're
willing to use it's not productive
sort of like susan collins being
perpetually disappointed by what donald
trump did
it's kind of a toothless uh phrase
but in any case it is going to be a drag
on the republican party and this is this
is a real challenge i don't
you know for years we've been hearing
demographic shifts mean
republicans will never win texas again
and like so far they keep winning texas
maybe at some point the demographic
shifts
will take texas from republicans this
combination of factors seems very
serious
uh 64 percent of republicans willing to
leave the party and follow trump to a
third party as we talked about earlier
the conservative media audience
increasingly split
between fox newsmax oan
and others the trumpy marjorie taylor
green
lauren beaubert madison cawthorne wing
of the republican party
increasingly at odds with people like
mitt romney not exactly a liberal
by any stretch of the imagination all of
these things together
really could spell disaster for the
republican party i hope it happens and
we'll continue following it